well the man behind the lens sees
Stephen Iliff joins me now very good
morning to you thanks so much for
joining us and I should say that
Darren's here too who's a British sign
language interpreter
so first of all Stephen tell us a little
bit about this exhibition death Mosaic
and what you want to achieve with it
so deaf mosaic
is a photography exhibition that shows
deaf people from a wide variety of
backgrounds occupations interests and so
on
and the reason for it is if you think
two years ago do you remember Rose
ailing Ellis
from Strictly Come Dancing when she won
and actually millions of people saw that
and felt the inspired by a deaf woman
achieving that
but at the same time many people don't
know about the other deaf people in The
Wider deaf community and their 90 000
deaf people in the community who have
different lives and achievements and so
my role as a photographer is to try to
capture their stories their achievements
and share them with the wider public so
so how did you choose your subjects in
particular
well I wanted to show deaf people can do
anything with the right support
and so I've got three examples that we
hope to talk about today which really
illustrate the different occupations and
interests that they have perfect and I
think we're going to start with Asher
aren't we she's an NHS nurse so tell us
a little bit about Asha and her job and
how she manages it
okay so Asha
she's a nurse in King's cross King's
College Hospital and she's a pediatric
nurse she works in critical care
and that's just one example of the
thousands of deaf people who work in
really crucial professional roles where
communication and teamwork is absolutely
vital
and her deafness doesn't stop that being
possible
how much support does she have to have
in order to do her job which is
challenging for all nurses absolutely
so all deaf people have different needs
some may speak for themselves some may
use sign language some may be able to
use both or switch between both so lots
of small adaptations can help from
asking people to face them making sure
there's clear lighting so they can lip
read
making sure that there's a minimum of
background noise
or actually more formal adaptations such
as providing specific equipment to help
with hearing
and so Asha uses a radio mic
with her team meetings
and sometimes she'll bring in a sign
language interpreter for training
courses and so on so lots of different
adaptations can make it possible really
interesting and obviously so important
that all the staff around are educated
as well and how to help her absolutely
and what about
um Jody she is a professional rugby
player so tell us a bit about her
so that's right Jody
is a remarkable story actually I think
because when she was small she really
wanted to play rugby
but her parents and teachers and the
coach were really worried about it
because Jody uses a cochlear implant
which is a surgical device to help
someone to hear better and they were
worried that in a contact sport like
rugby the impact would damage the
cochlear implant
but Jody felt that that's my risk to
take and she decided what she wanted to
do with her life
and so she asked for some adaptations to
the way that people play rugby with her
and she's become an elite professional
now
with Exeter Chiefs
and with the England rugby sevens
so she's asked teen colleagues just to
make small adaptations in the way that
they work with her and and it's worked
as you've seen fantastic and I think
she's going to be on Gladiators isn't
she absolutely right yeah guest
contestants so yeah watch Jody on
Gladiator it's just a few weeks time and
that is a fantastic example of TV
covering a powerful deaf woman and
providing deaf awareness great role
model I mean how important is that did
you have Role Models when you were
growing up deaf people in the public eye
well I think that is another reason why
um as a photographer I've photographed
those death Role Models because I was
mainstreamed in a local hearing school
and I was the only deaf child growing up
in that school and I had no deaf adults
that I knew about that I could learn
from or see as role models and so when I
thought about my career and my future I
thought there were many things that I
couldn't do that actually all I knew was
I couldn't use a phone so I couldn't do
that job I couldn't do this job and so I
just thought about the future of
something I can't do what I want to do
is show future generations of deaf
people hear what all these deaf people
that can do and have done so the
inspiration for you as well
that's so understandable having that
very visible role model there MC Giza is
our next example again a real
inspiration for young people I'm sure
tell them tell us a little bit about him
so there's a myth that deaf people can't
enjoy music
that we can't perform music and it's
just rubbish
some deaf people listen to music
or maybe experience music through
vibrations
particularly uh the beat through the
ground and MC Giza is one example of
someone who works in the field he does
that and he's part of a team called
Death rave
and they perform at concerts and
festivals and DJ sets they're a group of
DJs and MGS and sign language performers
and singers who go to festivals all over
the UK
amazing just amazing well Stephen I have
I could talk to you all day but we are
out of time and at